>>> HAPPY WEEK ONE NFL FOOTBALL
IS BACK.
THANK GOD IT IS FINALLY HERE.
HAPPY SUNDAY, EVERYONE.
YOU JUST TAPPED INTO THE R
BETTING SQUAD RITDE KINGS.
MY NAME IS CONNER ROGERS,
ALONGSIDE THE MAN OF THE PEOPLE,
YOU WANT TO GET ON HIS GOOD SIDE
BECAUSE YOU WANT TO WIN THESE
GIVE AWAYS.
THAT IS GREG IVORY.
I WANT WAIT FOR TODAY, GREG.
WHAT'S THE OVER UNDER NUMBER OF
HOODIES YOU'RE GIVING AWAY
TODAY?
>> OVER UNDER, CONNER, WHATEVER
IT IS, JUST HAMMER THE OVER.
MATTER OF FACT, LET ME INTRODUCE
THE PEOPLE THAT DON'T KNOW.
THIS RIGHT HERE IS THE HANDY
DANDY IPAD AND THIS IS HOW YOU
GET YOUR JERSEYS AND HOODIES.
THIS IS HOW I SEE YOU AND HOW
YOU SEE ME ON THE BLEACHER
REPORT APP.
YOU SEE WHAT I DID THERE,
CONNER.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
ABSOLUTELY.
>> ACTUALLY, I'M FEELING GOOD,
MAN.
IT'S NFL.
FIRST WEEK.
WEEK ONE.
ABOUT TO GIVE OUT HOODIES NOW.
WHY NOT?
ABOUT TO GIVE OUT HOODIES RIGHT
NOW.
I GOT MASTER JEDI SAYS USE THE
FORCE AND TRUST MASTER JEDI
JUSTIN JEFFERSON AND TRAVIS
KELSEY SCORES TOUCHDOWNS TODAY.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU MASTER JEDI.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH THE
FIRST HOODIE OF THE SQUAD RIDE
SHOW IN WEEK ONE.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU, MAN.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
YOU'VE SEEN A LOT OF PEOPLE
TAKING KELSEY.
HE'S GIVEN AWAY OUR JAM HERE A
BIT.
THIS IS THE SHOW WE'RE LOOKING
FOR ANY TIME TOUCHDOWN SCORES.
WHO IS GETTING IN THE END ZONE?
WE NEED TO KNOW.
THAT'S CHOSEN BY YOU, THE SQUAD.
THAT'S THE POINT OF THIS THING.
SO ON FRIDAY, WE ASKED YOU ON
SOCIAL.
WE ASKED YOU IN THE B.R. APP,
THE BETTING STREAM TO DROP YOUR
LOCKS TO SCORE A TOUCHDOWN.
THESE ARE THE MOST POPULAR PICKS
YOU SENT US SO FAR.
NO SURPRISE.
THE KING AT THE TOP, THE MAN
THAT FINDS THE END ZONE FEELS
LIKE EVERY WEEK IN DERRICK
HENRY.
SOME OTHER GOOD RUNS BACKS IN
DA
DALVIN COOK.
UNDER DOG PICKS HEALTHY FOR THE
NINERS GROUND ATTACK.
I KNOW THAT MAKES YOU HAPPY.
JONATHAN TAYLOR NEWCOMER ON THE
BLOCK IN FOR A HUGE YEAR AND
STEFON DIGGS LEADING THE BILLS
MAFIA CHARGE.
BEFORE WE GET STARTED, LET'S
REMIND YOU HOW THINGS GO.
LET'S LOOK AT SOME OF THE
FAVORITE LOCK LEGENDS OF LAST
YEAR.
>> OH, HEY, THERE BLEACHER
REPORT BETTING.
DELVIN COOK ON SUNDAY.
>> HIGH QUALITY.
>> AH!
♪
>> YES!
YES!
>> GUARANTEED TO GET A
TOUCHDOWN.
>> SUPERMAN TIME FOR NEW
ENGL
ENGLAND.
>> ZEKE IS MY PICK.
REALLY THINK HE'LL MAKE IT
HAPPEN.
>> WHO DAT, BABY?
WHO THE [ BLEEP ] DAT?
LET'S GO!
WOO!
♪
>> GREG, WE KNOW YOU'VE GOT THE
HO
HOODIES BUT WE'RE TAKING THINGS
UP A NOTCH.
WHAT DO YOU GOT FOR THE PEOPLE?
>> THAT'S RIGHT, CONNER.
I'M NOT ONLY GIVING AWAY HOODIES
BUT TWO, NOT ONE, TWO NFL JERSEY
GIFT CARDS.
ONE GOES TO THE WINNING LOCK
LEGEND CONTEST WE'RE ABOUT TO DO
AND ONE GOES TO A COMMENTATOR AT
THE END OF THE SHOW.
DO NOT GO ANYWHERE.
DO NOT LOG OUT.
STAY RIGHT HERE BECAUSE I'M
GIVING AWAY THIS JERSEY AND IT
MIGHT JUST BE YOU.
GET IN THE COMMENTS.
DO WHAT YOU DO.
IF YOU NEED A JERSEY, IF YOU
NEED A HOODIE, I NEED GIFTS AND
EMOJIS AND Y'ALL KNOW AND PHILIS
COMMENT IS UP.
Y'ALL KNOW WHAT I NEED.
I NEED WINNERS ONLY.
WINTERS ONLY PLEASE.
I MIGHT GIVE Y'ALL HOODIES.
CONNER, KEEP THIS THING GOING.
LET'S KEEP THIS THING GOING.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
WE HAVE FOUR LEGENDARY PICKS TO
SHOW YOU AND THE LAST ONE
STANDING ON TOP OF THE SQUAD
RIDE GETS AN ODD BOOST FROM
DRAFT KINGS SO STICK AROUND AND
SEE WHERE YOU CAN MAKE THE
MONEY, WHICH TOUCHDOWN SCORE
WILL GET BOOSTED THIS WEEK,
THAT'S WHAT ME AND GREG ARE HERE
TO DECIDE.
TIME FOR ROUND ONE, THE FIRST
PITCH COMES FROM MATT MATT, TELL
US WHAT IS SCORING A TOUCHDOWN
TODAY.
LET'S SEE THIS FIRST PITCH.
>> ALL RIGHT.
WE GOT TRAVIS KELSEY RIGHT HERE
FOR T.K. AND THEN WE GOT GEORGE
KITTLE HERE FOR G.K.
WHOEVER HITS IT CLOSE WILL SCORE
A TOUCHDOWN THIS WEEKEND.
>> THAT'S WHAT I'M TALKING
ABO
ABOUT.
>> RIGHT AT IT.
>> WHAT WE GOT?
ONE BALL RIGHT HERE.
WHO WE GOT?
T.K.
FLAG OVER THERE.
OVER HERE.
WHAT DO WE GOT?
WE GOT G.K., GEORGE KETTLE, WAY
CLOSER TO THE GEORGE KETTLE
TOUCHDOWN.
IT'S A FREAKING LOT.
LET'S GO.
>> SHOUTOUT TO MATT AND THE BOYS
THERE.
SHOT VIA MOTO RAZR.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> LET'S LOOK AT THE SECOND ONE
FROM SUCHI.
>> SEE HOW THIS GOES.
HOW ARE YOU DOING?
YOU CAN PAY FOR THE CAR BEHIND
ME, TOO.
I HAVE ONE QUESTION FOR YOU.
DO YOU WATCH FOOTBALL?
>> OH, YEAH, OH, YEAH.
>> PICK ONE PLAYER.
DEVONTE SMITH OR JONATHAN
TAYLOR.
>> PATRIOTS?
>> NO, PICK ONE OF THOSE
PLAYERS, DEVONTE SMITH OR
JONATHAN TAYLOR.
>> TAYLOR?
>> YEAH.
>> PERFECT.
THAT'S WHAT I'M GOING WITH.
>> I LOVE ASKING STRANGERS FOR
HELP IN THE BETTING WORLD.
WE'VE SEEN THE GOLF LEGENDS.
WE'VE SEEN THE TOLL BOOTH LEGEND
HIMSELF.
GREG?
WHAT DO YOU NEED FROM THE PEOPLE
NOW AND WHO ARE YOU ROLLING
WITH?
>> WHAT I NEED THE PEOPLE TO DO
IS GET IN THE COMMENTS AND TELL
ME WHO WE SHOULD HAVE MOVE ONTO
THE NEXT ROUND.
IS IT THE GOLF LEGEND OR THE
TOLL BOOTH LEGEND?
LET ME TALK ABOUT THESE VIDEOS.
CONNER, STARTING OFF WITH THE
GOLF LEGEND.
YOU KNOW ABOUT THE GOLF COURSE.
I KNOW.
I'VE SEEN YOU THERE PROBABLY
BEFORE ON INSTAGRAM OR TWITTER
OR WHATEVER.
WHAT DO THEY SAY, CONNER?
WHAT DO THEY SAY ABOUT YOUR
SWING?
IT'S ALL IN THE HIPS AND MY GUY
HAD THE MOTION.
HE HAD THE MOTION.
I LOVE THE PLAY GEORGE KITTLE
PLUS 125.
YOU KNOW THE NINERS ARE CLOSE TO
MY HEARDT.
THIS VIDEO MEANS SOMETHING TO
ME.
THIS MEANS SOMETHING MOVING ONTO
THE TOLL BOOTH LEGEND.
I LIKE MY GUY PAYING IT FORWARD.
HE PAID FOR THE GUY, THE PERSON
BEHIND HIM.
THAT IS ULTIMATE SUNSET VIBES
THERE.
THAT IS SUNSET.
THAT'S VIBES ALL AROUND.
THIS GUY DESERVES AN AWARD.
THE PICK IS GOOD, TOO.
JONATHAN TAYLOR, GOOD PICK,
CONNER.
IT IS A GOOD PICK.
I'M NOT GOING TO TELL YOU WHO I
LIKE.
LIKE, CONNER.
WHO DO YOU LIKE?
I'M TORN.
I'M HONESTLY TORN.
>> I AM, TOO.
YOU GOT TO LIVE IT PLUS 125
ISN'T BAD.
I LIKE THE ATHLETICISM.
THE GUYS ARE ON THE COURSE
HAVING A GOOD TIME BUT MAN,
GREG, I'M ROLLING WITH JONATHAN
TAYLOR.
NOT ONLY DO I LIKE THE PICK, I
LIKE THE STYLE, LIKE YOU SAID,
HE PAID FOR THE PEOPLE BEHIND
HIM.
ASK A COMPLETE STRANGER.
YOU DON'T KNOW IF HE WATCHES
FOOTBALL.
A LITTLE BIT.
MAYBE.
THAT'S WHAT YOU SAY WHEN YOU
DON'T KNOW HOW TO ANSWER BUT THE
MAN WAS DECISIVE AND WENT WITH
JONATHAN TAYLOR.
WHAT SIDE ARE THE PEOPLE ON NOW,
GREG?
>> CONNER, LET ME GRAND THIS
HANDY DANDY IPAD.
I GOT K.P. GIANTS HERE WITH THE
GIFT.
I KNOW YOU GUYS CAN SEE IT
THERE.
THAT IS JONATHAN TAYLOR.
WINNERS ON, PLEASE.
LOOK AT THE VALUE.
SHOUTOUT.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
CAME FAST.
ALSO A GIFT OF JONATHAN TAYLOR
HITTING THE WHOA, HITTING THE
WHOA THERE IT IS RIGHT THERE.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
LET'S MAKE A DECISION.
I THINK IT'S TIME TO MAKE A
DECISION.
I'M SEEING A LOT OF GEORGE
KITTLE.
SHOUTOUT TO EVERYONE SAYING
GEORGE KITTLE BUT I SEE MORE
JONATHAN TAYLORS IN THE COMMENTS
SO THEREFORE, CONNER, IT APPEARS
SUCHI IS MOVING ONTO THE NEXT
ROUND.
THIS HURTS MY HEART.
YOU KNOW HOW I FEEL ABOUT GEORGE
KITTLE.
>> YEAH, YOU DO.
SUCHI WELL DONE.
BUT WE STILL HAVE TWO MORE
ROUNDS.
YOU'RE NOT IN THE CLEAR YET.
WE'RE NOT RIDING WITH JONATHAN
TAYLOR JUST YET ON TO ROUND TWO.
OUR NEXT PITCH COMES FROM
RILEY SOROB.
WHAT DO YOU GOT?
>> OH, MAN.
NOTHING LIKE SOME ICE CREAM.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
SOME ICE CREAM TO HELP ME MAKE
SOME LOCKS TODAY.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
DANG IT.
WHAT THE?
NO WAY.
DERRICK HENRY.
TEAM DERRICK HENRY IT IS.
RIDE IT.
>> THE SPRINKLE LEGEND GOING
WITH DERRICK HENRY.
THAT'S A SMART MAN.
GET YOUR ICE CREAM AND GO WITH
THE SAFEST PICK OF THE WEEK.
THE GUY THAT SCORES HAS LED THE
LEAGUE IN RUSHING TOUCHDOWNS NOW
FOR THE LAST TWO YEARS.
GREG, WE'RE DOWN HERE AT THE
TOLL BOOTH LEGEND, THE SPRINKLE
LEGEND, WHO DO YOU LIKE, WHO DO
OUR PEOPLE LIKE?
>> EVERYBODY THAT'S WATCHING
LOOK AT YOUR PHONE.
LOOK AT YOUR TABLET.
WHATEVER YOU'RE ON.
YOUR DEVICE.
GET YOUR FINGERS READY AND START
TYPING WHO YOU THINK SHOULD MOVE
ONTO THE NEXT ROUND.
SHOULD IT BE SPRINKLE LEGEND OR
TOLL BOOTH LEGEND?
YOU GUYS LET ME KNOW.
LET ME HOP IN HERE.
CONNER, IF YOU DO NOT KNOW LAST
YEAR RILEY SORBO IS A LEGEND.
I'M GOING TO GET TO IT.
I'LL TELL YOU EVERYTHING THAT HE
DID FOR US LAST YEAR BUT HE'S A
LEGEND.
HE'S THE McDONALD LEGEND.
HE'S THE FOREIGN LEGEND.
I CAN KEEP GOING BUT HE'S A
LEGEND AND WE NEED TO SAY HIS
NAME RILEY SORBO.
HE'S A LEGEND.
THIS VIDEO HERE, DERRICK HENRY
MINUS 225 SPRINKLES, EVERYTHING
HE DID -- IT LOOKED LIKE A
MASTERPIECE.
IT LOOKED LIKE A TIKTOK I WOULD
LIKE.
I LIKE IT.
I LIKE THE VIDEO.
I LIKE THE PICK.
I'M DONE TALKING.
CONNER, WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> I'M A HUGE FAN OF THIS.
MINUS 225.
LET'S BOOST THE ODDS TODAY.
I'M SELFISHLY ROOTING FOR THIS
ONE, GREG.
I LOVE THE CONCEPT AND EXECUTION
THERE.
THE SPRINKLE LEGEND, I THINK THE
SPRINKLE LEGEND HAS TO BE MOVING
ON BUT GREG, YOU STILL GOT TO
GIVE AWAY HOODIES AND LET THE
PEOPLE PICK.
WHAT ARE THEY SAYING NOW?
>> CONNER, LET ME GET INTO THE
COMMENTS BECAUSE I THINK THEY
ARE RIGHT THERE WITH YOU.
I SEE A LOT OF SPRINKLES.
SHOUTOUT TO DANIEL WITH THE GUY
DRINKING A LOT OF SPRINKLES.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU, BRO.
I GOT NY 22 GC AND DERRICK HENRY
CLAPPING AND IT'S ALABAMA
UNIFORM.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU NY 22 GC.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I GOT SQUAD RIDE.
SQUAD RIDE.
I SEE WHAT YOU DID THERE.
THEY GOT THE SQUAD RIDE AS THEIR
BLEACHER REPORT HANDLE NAME.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU FOR THE
CREATIVITY.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A HAD
DE
-- HOODIE AND DERRICK HENRY.
IT'S A CLEAR CUT.
I DON'T SEE ANY.
GUESS WHAT.
RILEY ONCE AGAIN YOU'RE MOVING
ONTO THE NEXT ROUND.
>> RILEY MOVING ON.
WELL DONE, WE'RE NOT DONE YET.
WE GOT ONE MORE ROUND HERE THAT
RILEY HAS TO GET THROUGH ANOTHER
CONTENDER.
WE WANT TO SEE WHO IS GETTING
THIS JERSEY.
WE WANT TO SEE WHO IS MORE
IMPORTANTLY GOING TO BE THE
SQUAD RIDE LEADER OF THIS WEEK
OF WEEK ONE OF THE NFL SEASON.
ALL RIGHT.
NEXT UP, W TRAMMEL HOPEFULLY
BRINGING THE HEAT.
>> V.R. NATION WEEK ONE ANY TIME
A TOUCHDOWN SCORE.
♪
>> COME ON.
>> STEFON DIGGS.
>> THE BUCKET LEGEND, THE BUCKET
TOSS CHALLENGE STEFON DIGGS.
LOVE THAT.
DID YOU SEE THE BUCKETS, THE
CUSTOM THERE.
THEY'RE OUT THERE HAVING A GOOD
TIME.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THIS ONE?
>> HEY, THE CUSTOM MADE BUCKETS
ARE LEGENDARY.
THE THROW WAS LEGENDARY.
THE POOL -- LOOKED LIKE A LAZY
RIVER WAS LEGENDARY.
THIS WHOLE VIDEO WAS LEGENDARY.
DIGGS, YOU KNOW HOW I FEEL ABOUT
THIS BUFFALO BILLS TEAM THIS
YEAR.
COME ON.
PLUS 100?
YOU KNOW WHAT WE DO HERE.
WE'RE GOING TO ODDS BOOST IT.
I THINK I MIGHT BE LEANING
TOWARDS THIS BUCKET LEGEND
CONNER.
WHAT ARE YOU THINKING?
>> MAN, IT'S MY FAVORITE CONCEPT
YET BUT NOT MY FAVORITE PICK.
I THINK THE BILLS WILL BEAT THE
STEELERS TODAY.
I THINK STEFON DIGGS IS ONE OF
THOSE GUYS THAT IS GOOD FOR TEN
TARGETS EVERY WEEK AND THERE IS
A GOOD CHANCE HE SCORES.
I KNOW DERRICK HENRY IS GOING TO
SCORE.
HE PROBABLY SCORES TWICE AND I'M
TRYING TO GET THE ODDS BOOSTED
FOR THE SPRINKLE LEGEND.
I'M BEING SELFISH.
I WANT THIS TO HAPPEN.
WHO IS OUR FIRST SQUAD LEADER OF
THIS SEASON, GREG?
>> CONNER, I AM IN THE COMMENTS.
YOU ARE HILARIOUS, BRO.
YOU SAID YOU KNOW DERRICK HENRY
IS GOING TO SCORE.
I FEEL YOU, MAN.
I LIKE THAT GUARANTEED MONEY, AS
WELL.
LET ME GET INTO THESE COMMENTS
AND IT APPEARS THAT THE PEOPLE
IN THE COMMENTS KNOW DERRICK
HENRY IS GOING TO SCORE, AS WELL
BECAUSE I'M SEEING A LOT OF
DERRICK HENRY IN THE -- HOLD ON.
HOLD ON.
THESE COMMENTS ARE MOVING.
I'M ALSO SEEING STEFON DIGGS.
THEY ARE RIDING WITH ME.
I GOT TRASHED, TRASHED SAYS
STEFON DIGGS.
HE THREW A GIF IN.
I GOT ESTEBON CAR DONED OCHO
CA.
I'LL KEEP GOING.
I SEE SPRINKLES MRIZ 3.
MRIZ 3 HAS SPRINKLES ALL OVER
THE BOARD.
LAST ONE.
I'LL MAKE A DECISION.
>> IT'S CRUNCH TIME.
>> IT'S CRUNCH TIME AND I JUST
WANT THEM TO KEEP ON FLOWING.
YOU KNOW, SO I CAN GET A GOOD
LOOK AT WHAT WE SHOULD DECIDE
AND IT APPEARS WE ARE GOING TO
GO WITH DERRICK HENRY.
>> SMART --
>> WE'LL GO WITH DERRICK HENRY
BECAUSE OF ABLE MATCH SAYS KING
HENRY DON'T MISS.
KING HENRY DON'T MISS.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH THE
HOODIE AND THAT MEANS MY GUY,
THE LEGEND, THE SQUAD RIDE HALL
OF FAMER, LET'S JUST MAKE HIM
THAT NOW.
LET'S CALL HIM THE SQUAD HALL OF
FAMER.
RALEIGH SORBO IS THE WINNER OF
THE FIRST WEEK'S SQUAD RIDE
LOCKS LEGEND VIDEO CONTEST.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU, RILEY.
YOU MAY KNOW HIM AS THE
CHAMELEON LEGEND OR OLD McDONALD
LEGEND.
HE'S TRADED IN ANIMALS FOR US
FOR ICE CREAM AND NOW HE IS OUR
SPRINKLE LEGEND.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU, RILEY.
YOU ARE TAKING HOME A JERSEY.
PLEASE, PLEASE, PLEASE PULL UP
THAT GRAPHIC FOR ME.
PLEASE PULL UP THE GRAPHIC.
THERE IT IS.
>> THAT'S IT.
>> YOU GUYS SEE DERRICK HENRY.
YOU GUYS SEE DERRICK HENRY RIGHT
THERE?
CONNER, HAVE YOU SEEN MAGIC
BEFORE APPEAR ON YOUR SCREEN?
>> NO, I'M READY FOR THIS.
>> DURING THE SHOW.
LET ME SHOW YOU GUYS MAGIC.
ARE YOU READY?
THERE WE GO.
POOF.
SAW THAT?
>> BOOM.
>> DID YOU SEE THAT?
DID YOU SEE THAT?
THAT'S WHAT WE DO HERE.
WE CHANGE ODDS JUST LIKE THAT
LIKE IT'S MAGIC.
THANKS TO OUR FRIENDS AT DRAFT
KINGS.
WE'LL GET THE BOOST FOR YOU GUYS
FROM MINUS 225 TO MINUS 150.
CHECK OUT BR BETTING SOCIALS FOR
A LINK.
MAKE SURE YOU CHECK US OUT ON
SOCIALS TO GET LINKS TO THE OUT
BOOST AND SEND US SCREEN SHOTS
OF YOUR BETS.
LET'S GET RICH, CONNER.
LET'S GET RICH.
IT'S FOOTBALL.
LET'S GET RICH SUNDAY.
SEND US YOUR VIDEOS AND TAG YOUR
CELEBRATIONS BUT REMEMBER,
PLEASE REMEMBER, AND FILL THE
COMMENTS UP ONCE AGAIN.
WINNERS ONLY PLEASE, CONNER.
WE NEED WINNERS ON, PLEASE.
>> GREG, I KNOW THE HALL OF
FAMER IS THE GOLD JACKET.
FOR US RILEY WILL BE GETTING
FITTED IN A GREEN JACKET.
WELL DONE, RILEY.
WE'RE NOT DONE.
THE LEGENDS MIGHT BE DONE.
WE GOT MORE LOCKS TO TALK.
WE GOT HOODIES TO GIVE AWAY AND
STILL HAVE A JERSEY TO GIVE AWAY
SO DON'T GO ANYWHERE.
AND NOW, IT'S THE COMMUNITY
COMMENT CONTEST HERE.
WE WANT TO SEE SOME BEST BETS.
IF YOU HANG OUT IN THE COMMUNITY
STREAM IN THE BLEACHER REPORT
APP, WE ASKED YOU WEEK ONE WHAT
ARE YOUR BEST BETS?
YOU HAVE ALL SUMMER TO THINK
ABOUT THIS, NOT SIX DAYS.
YOU HAVE THE ENTIRE SUMMER TO
GET CRAZY.
WE PICKED TWO OF THE FAVORITE
COMMENTS, WE WANT TO KNOW WHAT
YOU THINK OF EACH OF THESE.
>> YES, YES, YES.
I NEED YOU TO GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND TELL ME WHICH OF
THESE IS THE BETTER TAKE.
YOU GUYS GOT TO LET ME KNOW
WHICH ONE OF THESE IS THE BETTER
TAKE.
ACTUALLY, LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT
IT RIGHT NOW.
WE GOT SSP RIGHT HERE SAYS
CALVIN RIDLEY LEAVE THE
LEAGUE --
>> PRETTY BOLD.
>> THIS IS A BOLD ONE.
THIS IS A BOLD ONE, CONNER.
LET'S MOVE ONTO THE NEXT ONE.
WE HAVE TWO TONE NOT POST
MALONE, NOT CORALARL MALONE BUT
TONE MALONE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK, MAN?
>> I THINK WE JUMP TO OUR NEXT
SEGMENT, WHICH IS BOLDEST BETS.
THIS IS SUPPOSED TO BE BEST
BETS.
EACH OF THESE ARE PRETTY BOLD
AND I RESPECT THAT.
I LIKE IT.
THEY'RE LOOKING TO MAKE MONEY.
LET'S START WITH THE LAST ONE.
TITANS COMING OUT OF THE AFC,
TITANS IN THE SUPER BOWL JUST
SOUNDS CRAZY.
THEY GOT A REALLY, REALLY GOOD
TEAM AND MADE GREAT MOVES THIS
OFF SEASON AND EXCITED TO SEE
JULIO JONES THERE AND MIKE CAN
COACH UP THE DEFENSE.
DO WE THINK THEY'RE GETTING BY
THE CHIEFS OR BROWNS OR THE
PATRIOTS OR BALTIMORE?
I DON'T KNOW.
IT'S A TOUGH ONE FOR ME.
I'M ACTUALLY LIKING THE CALVIN
RIDLEY THERE, GREG.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT CALVIN RIDLEY A
TARGET MONSTER IN AN OFFENSE
THAT LOST JULIO JONES WHO IS THE
MAN FOR A DECADE.
CALVIN RIDLEY IS ONE OF THE MOST
UNDERRATED RECEIVERS.
KYLE PITS WILL HAVE MOMENTS
THERE THAT MAKES ME A LITTLE
SKEPTICAL.
THERE IS NO REASON HE CAN'T GET
TEN TARGET AS GAME AND AT LEAST
HAVE A SHOT TO BE THE RESEEING
LE
-- RECEIVING LEADER.
I LIKE IT.
>> CONNER, HONESTLY, THE PEOPLE
IN THE COMMENTS ARE AGREEING
WITH YOU, TOO.
SEEING CALVIN RIDLEY IN THE
COMMENTS.
I'LL START GIVING OUT JERSEYS, I
MEAN, NOT JERSEYS BUT HOODIES.
>> THEY WISH.
>> HERE WE GO.
I GOT GUNS BURGER SAYS CALVIN
RIDLEY, SHOUT OOUT TO YOU.
JACK BOY 37 SAYS CALVIN RIDLEY
IS A LOCK TO THE LEAGUE.
HEARD IT HERE FIRST.
YOU PEOPLE ARE REALLY, REALLY
BOLD WITH THIS CALVIN RIDLEY
PLAY.
I'LL JUST ANNOUNCE IT.
SSP 17 YOU WON, MAN.
SSP 17, YOU WON THE COMMENT
CONTEST.
YOU'RE GETTING THE HOODIE, AS
WELL.
SSP 17 FOR YOUR CALVIN RIDLEY
TAKE.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU, MAN.
YOU'RE A LEGEND.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> THE B.R. BETTING SQUAD RIGHT
SHOW.
>> BEST BETS IN THE BOOK.
NOW TIME FOR BOLDEST BETS.
THIS IS WHERE I WANT THE
COMMENTS INVOLVED, GREG.
BOLDEST BETS.
WHO WILL LOOK SMART, WHO WILL
LOOK MAYBE NOT DUMB BECAUSE
THESE ARE LONG SHOTS AND
COMPLETE DARK THROWS HERE.
THESE ARE NOT LOCKS.
THIS IS TIME TO HAVE FUN.
LET'S GET CRAZY AND PUT A COUPLE
HUNDRED BUCKS DOWN.
WHAT DO YOU NEED FROM THE PEOPLE
FOR BOLDEST BETS?
>> GET IN THE COMMENT AND TELL
ME WHETHER YOU'RE RIDING WITH
ME, WHICH YOU SHOULD BE OR IF
YOU'RE RIDING WITH MY GUY CONNER
ROGERS OVER THERE IN HIS LOCKS
OR HIS PLAY OR HIS BOLDEST BET,
WHATEVER HE PLAYS, YEAH.
>> THIS IS GOING TO BE A
MARATHON.
WE GOT TO GET READY FOR THIS ONE
NOW.
I THINK THE PEOPLE MAYBE SHOULD
GO WITH YOU, HONESTLY.
LET'S GET RIGHT INTO IT.
MY BOLDEST BET OF THE WEEK A
FIVE PICK PARLAY.
THESE ODDS ARE OVER PLUS 1600.
OVER PLUS 1600.
LET'S START WITH JETS' PANTHERS
TJ JOHNSON.
OVER 24.5 RUSHING YARDS.
MY GOD.
THAT SHOULD BE FOUR CARRIES.
BRANDON, YOUR BOY GREG OVER 3.5
RECEPTIONS IS IN FOR A MONSTER
YEAR FOR THE 49ERS.
KYLE PITS, THE NUMBER TWO OPTION
IN ATLANTA OVER 3.5 RECEPTIONS
AGAINST THE EAGLES.
RAMS, FIRST HALF TOTAL.
OVER 13.5.
JUST NEED TWO TOUCHDOWNS FROM
YOU IN THE FIRST HALF, RAMS.
THAT'S ALL WE'RE ASKING FOR.
SEAN McVEIGH ALL SUMMER MATT
STAFFORD WE HEARD HOW GOOD YOU
ARE YOU.
THE LAST ONE KAREEM HUNT OVER
16.5 RECEIVING YARDS.
MAN, THAT'S ONE SCREEN PASS FOR
KAREEM HUNT THE TACKLE BREAKING
MACHINE PLUS 16-10 HERE.
I THINK IT'S A LITTLE CRAZY
HERE.
>> HOLD ON.
LOVE THE FANTASY TEAM.
I ABSOLUTELY LOVE THAT PLAY OVER
3 P
3.3.
KIND OF SKEPTICAL.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE RAMS'
PLAY, CONNER.
THIS RAMS' PLAY.
THE RAMS TO WIN THE NFC AND NFC
WEST.
IS THE HYPE REALLY REAL?
LIKE DO YOU THINK THAT THIS
OFFENSE IS GOING TO BE ONE OF
THE HIGH POWERED OFFENSES OF THE
LEAGUE OR SOMETHING?
LIKE WHAT IS GOING ON?
>> I THINK ANDY DOLTON IS GOING
TO THROW AT LEAST AN
INTERCEPTION OR TWO IN THE FIRST
HALF AND THE RAMS HAVE AT LEAST
ONE OFFENSIVE TOUCHDOWN AND
DEFENSIVE TOUCHDOWN.
THIS IS MORE ABOUT THE BEARS.
I'M SORRY, BEARS FANS.
WHEN JUSTIN FIELDS GETS IN
THERE, I CAN'T WAIT TO WATCH
YOUR TEAM AND YOU'LL TURN IT
AROUND.
ANDY DOLTON WEEK ONE AGAINST THE
RAMS, IT 'S A LONG SHOT.
LET'S HAVE FUN, MAN.
WHAT DO YOU GOT?
>> YOU MIGHT WANT TO CASH OUT A
LITTLE EARLY.
>> I PROBABLY WILL.
I WON'T TELL YOU GUYS BUT I
PROBABLY WILL.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> IT'S ALL GOOD.
LET ME TELL YOU, MY BOLDEST BET
TODAY I THINK IS GOING TO BE A
TRACK MEET IN DETROIT.
SO THE NINERS, I TOOK THE
ALTERNATE SPREAD HERE.
I'M TAKING THE NINERS ALTERNATE
SPREAD IN DETROIT.
THEY WILL WIN BY MORE THAN TWO
TOUCHDOWNS.
THIS MIGHT GET UGLY.
THE LIONS, THEIR OFFENSIVE LINE
IS DEPLETED.
THEY DON'T HAVE A LEFT TACKLE
AND WE KNOW THE 49ERS DEFENSIVE
LINE, GUYS WHO LOVE TO GET TO
THE QUARTERBACK.
I SEE THIS ONE BEING UGLY.
RAHEEM, TREY, MAYBE MIGHT SEE
SOME TREY LANCE TODAY, CONNER.
MIGHT GET UGLY OUT THERE IN
DETROIT WITH THE NINERS MINUS
13.
>> I'M WITH YOU ALL THE WAY.
THIS WILL BE A BLOWOUT.
I THINK THE LIONS ARE CLEARLY IN
A REBUILD.
I THINK THAT PASS RUSH WILL GET
JARED GOFF OFF PLATFORM, NOT A
PRETTY PLACE FOR HIM TO BE.
WE KNOW THE NINERS CAN RUN THE
BALL.PROBABLY THE BEST GOING
BACK TO WHEN HIS DAD WAS THE
COACH OF THE BRONCOS.
THIS GUY LIVED RUNNING THE
FOOTBALL.
I LOVE YOU BROUGHT THAT UP.
THAT'S AS HIGH AS THEY LET YOU
GO IS THAT MINUS 13.
NINERS WIN BY TWO TOUCHDOWNS.
ARE THE PEOPLE AGREEING WITH
EITHER OF US ARE WE BOTH INSANE?
>> LET ME SEE.
LET ME SEE, CONNER.
I AM IN THE COMMENTS.
I GOT ONE SAYING KYLE PITS 100%
YOUNG STUD.
I HAVE TO GIVE HIM THAT BECAUSE
HE SWITCHED AND THREW A
CURVEBALL.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
LET ME SEE.
I SEE NINERS ONLY PLEASE FOR
GREG EVERY WEEK.
JOE, I SEE YOU.
I SEE YOU.
THE NINERS ARE GOING TO WIN YOU
SOME MONEY.
JUST WATCH.
HERE WE GO.
CONNER TO BE HONEST, BRO, WE
SMITH 44 SAID ROLLING WITH G
MONEY 21 PLUS.
SHO
SHOUTOUT TO YOU WALKING AWAY
WITH A HOODIE.
>> A JERSEY.
>> YEAH, I WAS ABOUT TO SAY.
SHOULD I GIVE AWAY A JERSEY,
TOO, RIGHT NOW?
>> YES.
>> HERE WE GO.
GIVING AWAY A JERSEY.
HERE WE GO, CONNER.
BILL ORAZA 94 SAYS RIDING WITH
CONNER.
>> LET'S GO!
>> CRAZY OF A PARLAY, NOT THAT
CRAZY OF A PARLAY PLUS THE HUNT
LEG.
I LOST IT.
HE SAID PLUS THE HUNT LEG.
SO IF HE WAS RIDING WITH YOU,
CONNER.
SO THEREFORE, HERE IT GO.
HE SAID THE HUNT LEG.
THE HUNT LEG.
THE RECEIVING YARDS FOR KAREEM
HUNT, HE SAID THAT SOLD HIM.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU BILL.
IF I'M BUTCHERING YOUR NAME.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
JERSEY.
CONNER, FOOTBALL.
>> IT'S ABOUT THAT TIME.
>> ALMOST UPON US.
IT MIGHT BE TIME TO GET ON UP
OUT OF HERE.
>> I THINK IT IS.
GOOD LUCK WITH YOUR WAGERS,
EVERYONE.
LET'S MAKE MONEY.
WINNERS ON PLEASE.
CONGRATS TO ALL THE HOODIE AND
JERSEY WINNERS.
I THINK A LOT OF YOU ARE WALKING
AWAY QUITE HAPPY TODAY AND IF
YOU'RE NOT, COME BACK NEXT WEEK.
WE DO THIS EVERY SUNDAY AT 11:00
A.M. GETTING THE BLEACHER REPORT
ON THE WEST COAST, WAKE UP
EARLY.
GREG DOES IT.
WHY CAN'T EVERYONE ELSE DO IT?
IF YOU WON, BR BETTING WILL DM
YOU.
THEY WILL FIND A WAY TO CONTACT
YOU AND MAKE SURE YOU GET
EVERYTHING.
THANK YOU TO EVERYONE THAT
COMMENTED.
THANK YOU TO THE LEGENDS, MATT,
SUCHI, RILEY SORBO.
A LOT OF CREATIVITY WAS BROUGHT
FOR WEEK ONE AND IT WILL ONLY
GET BETTER FROM HERE.
ENJOY YOUR FOOTBALL SUNDAY.
DROP YOUR REALTIME TAKES IN
THE --
>> WHOA, WHOA, WHOA --
>> CONNER?
>> I KNOW THIS IS YOUR SECOND
SHOW BUT I GOT TO GIVE THE
PEOPLE LOVE AT THE END OF THE
SHOW.
THEY'RE HERE FOR THE HOODIES.
THEY'RE HERE FOR THE JERSEYS SO
YOU KNOW, I'M A MAN OF THE
PEOPLE.
I GOT TO HOOK THEM UP.
I'M BACK INTO THE COMMENTS,
CONNER.
I'M BACK INTO THE COMMENTS REAL
QUICK TO GIVE AWAY SOME MORE
HOODIES TO THE PEOPLE THAT STUCK
AROUND UNTIL THE END OF THE
SHOW.
I GOT THE REAL ONES, THE REAL
ONES, THE REAL ONES.
I GOT NOT MITCH TRUBISKY.
BRANDON AIYUK AND SHOUTOUT.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I'M NOT EVEN GOING TO TRY TO
PRONOUNCE THAT, THAT WAS FOR THE
PRODUCERS.
THEY SAID WADDLE.
WADDLE --
>> I LIKE THAT.
>> THE ROOKIE FROM ALABAMA.
SHOUT
SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
YOU WALK AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
THAT'S IT.
DANIEL LEVEE.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
>> I LOVE IT.
A MAN OF THE PEOPLE.
GREG IVORY.
I'M CONNER ROGERS.
COME BACK SAME TIME, SAME PLACE
EVERY WEEK AND GET A HOODIE, GET
A JERSEY, GET SOME LOCKS AND
MAKE MONEY.
THANKS, EVERYONE.
CATCH YOU NEXT WEEK.